for every one division fan theory that
turned out to be right there were many
more times one division story zigged
when people thought it would zag
many of us confidently identified early
on that agnes was actually agatha
harkness who would go on to be the
show's big bad by season's end but that
proved to be the exception and not the
rule
when evan peters turned up claiming to
be wanda's dead brother pietro maximoff
for example
people immediately left to the
conclusion that this was proof of a
full-on
x-men mcu crossover after all aaron
taylor johnson played pietro in the
mcu's age of ultron whereas peters was a
part of the former fox x-men lineup with
the next doctor strange movie entitled
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness there was every reason to
suspect more of fox's mutants were on
the way
another major question arose thanks to a
cheeky comment paul bettany made in an
interview with esquire indicating the
show had one more major cameo coming
before season's end
betany said it's an actor i've longed to
work with all my life
and we have some amazing scenes together
and the chemistry between us is
i think extraordinary and it was just
fireworks on set
who could it be sir ian mcallen is
magneto maybe mark hamill
the guesses were all over the place in
the end both of these big questions were
answered in ways that punked fans a
little
peters was playing a nobody actor named
ralph boner controlled by agatha
boner boner
and the actor betany had great chemistry
with was himself as white vision
naturally fans had pretty strong
reactions to the twin deceptions and now
elizabeth olsen herself has stepped in
to respond
in an interview with variety olson spoke
about fan theories picking on both the
true identity of peter maximoff and
bethany's promise of a final cameo
she said i knew that there are theories
that had to do with people wanting more
surprises and cameos but i'm not really
that aware what these fan theories were
so i'm kind of learning about it as we
go
paul said something about this crazy
cameo when he was really just talking
about doing a scene with himself and i
know paul thought that was a really
funny joke and i thought it was funny
but i was like i think people are
actually going to suspect that there is
more to come
i'm starting
to believe that everything is
meaningless spoiler fans most certainly
did think there was more to come
as for evan peters playing pietro olson
pointed out that the possibility of a
fox disney crossover wasn't even on her
radar yet
she said i didn't know about the
multiverse when we were filming this so
i wouldn't assume that that's what was
happening
i thought it was just a clever way to
have pietro i didn't understand the
larger plan of the multiverse until i
started working on multiverse or
whatever our movie's called the dr
strange sequel it's worth noting that
this is the second occasion where a
multiverse has been hinted at but not
delivered
there are multiple realities peter this
is earth dimension 616. i'm from
earth833
i'm sorry you're saying there's a
multiverse the first time took place in
spider-man far from home and mysterio
tricked people into thinking he was from
an alternate universe when he's actually
just a very elaborate illusionist and
thief
paul bettany also weighed in on the
topic during an appearance on good
morning america
he asked of the host you know when you
think something's gonna be funny and
then you say it and you actually panic
about it
which is what i did because fans started
guessing who it might be and they were
guessing like benedict cumberbatch or
patrick stewart
i was thinking god that's a good idea
and they're gonna be so disappointed
when they find out it's me
is it really you while some fans may be
annoyed at the subterfuge white vision
is an important part of the ongoing
wanda envision love story
after all with west view's version of
vision gone the only hope wanda
currently has for another chance with
her husband is through the white vision
it was last seen flying away to parts
unknown
as for the ph or fake out this isn't the
first time marvel pulled something like
this
in iron man 3 sir ben kingsley was
supposedly cast to play the mandarin but
it turned out just like with peters to
be an actor named trevor slattery
of course evan peters could still play
pietro in the mcu someday and sir
patrick stewart or sir ian mckellen
could turn up his mutants eventually too
this could all just be a long com and
the multiverse is still upon us
somehow check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite mcu tv shows
and movies are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one